i actually don't talk to my mom you know
ironically she called cps on me when i
was in the trauma center i don't know
what kind of you know mom or childhood
protective services yeah and my stepdad
conundring up some like craziness
but um at for now my mom is you know in
my heart always will be but it's not a
good thing why did she call cps
i don't have her brain why do these
things happen to me what was her claim
i attacked her actually
you clapped your daughter you attacked
your daughter i attacked my mother
on the yacht on my birthday
and were you on a yacht on your birthday
yes and i only invited my parents
because i was so traumatized for my
sexual assault i didn't have a big
birthday party like i normally did
were you sexually assaulted recently um
it's been a year now i just did like my
one year anniversary of it did that
person that sexually assaulted you get
charged
um that's the court stuff that i'm
dealing with right now so i think like
that's best with my attorney um
investigations still go um you have so
many things to talk about but nothing
that can be mentioned
um you can totally google it
you know he's the one who brought up my
name and stepped down from his job and i
think that was like it was a really
public official right it was a
is that right google it yeah it was a
public official i think in is that is
that okay listen i don't wanna are then
welcome to do it
but i don't want to also because i'm an
advocate for mental health i don't want
to trigger you you know what i am not
triggered anymore and i came out of
trauma center so please let's use the
trauma tools go for it so then put it up
on google caroline's doing it she's
actually okay with it are you actually
okay i don't wanna i don't wanna and
i've also i'm kind of nervous talking to
you
because i don't wanna trigger you
oh it's the mayor the california mayor
resigns amid assault accusations the
mayor of california what they kept at
palm beach right it wasn't los angeles
it was i was actually in florida when
this happened um on spring break so i
have to just warn ladies when you're on
spring break
i would just say a lot of rapists are
out yeah but yeah so watch out and i
know we're in california she's one uh oh
wait wait the 38 year old mayor and i'm
not
this is alleged right now i love that we
get to read this because i don't read
these i love that we get to do this can
i read it is it it's okay because this
is the first time hearing of it and i
don't want to be some step this let's do
it okay and i don't want to be i'm just
saying i'm reading something what am i
reading
this is online on the rap i don't know
i'm not condoning this teen mom star
fair abraham and eight other eight other
women
eight other women have accused
northern california do you not know that
did you not know that i only thought
there was like five but i don't know
you're shocked by another three three
you're only off like i'm sure there's
way more if there's only that you know
uh northern i don't even want to say his
name the uh accused of the mayor of uh
northern california town of sexual
assault and he resigned hmm oh wow
oh oh my gosh in palm beach florida no
it says here oh that's where it was yeah
had you been dating this person or you
just met this person once i only met
this person um
once but only for like hours it was at a
wine tasting i only learned about the
wine tasting an hour before i was
invited to that and i think
that is you know even if you're with
people who you think you know for years
and you've traveled with them you know
there's a lot of gistly and maxwell's
out there and i really learned a lot um
so it's horrible
there's no joke here yeah you know what
i think sometimes we think things will
never happen to us
and
i realized like
i'm not you know bionic and things will
happen to me so i just have yeah 12 step
it like
don't you keep saying 12 12 steps
don't let the defects of my character
you know get to me that step six i like
love that one the best but it's really
being empowered with your higher power
and having that with you at all times
but for some reason when i got like
really messed up my nervous system i was
in chronic pain i don't wish this on
anyone
um so i got to learn a lot about myself
this year and i got to take a lot of
time off i wish i you know wasn't a
workaholic but it really bothered me and
i think once your foot is just like
stuck in something and in pain
other bad things are attracted to you
like i was walking down the street in
beverly hills in confusion and some guy
was gonna stab me with a shrubber
shredder and he's in jail right now with
a what a shrub or shredder
and then the issue with the gentleman
handcuffing me on the sidewalk the issue
with going to work and four people
attack so you think you're drawing this
in this negativity well that's why i
went to the trauma center and i wanted
to figure out what it was what is it yes
so when you are stuck in the point like
your foot's stuck in a hole and you're
fearful of one thing your fear will keep
attracting to you i believe that the law
of attraction i do believe in the law of
attraction why would i attract only
great and good now and i'm past the
stuck point but that i think is why
other men were attacking me after this
in beverly hills because no but i think
this gentleman was
was it a homeless person yes i think
sadly
[Music]